where he's a associate professor of
Economics telling us about improving
refugee resettlement thank you so much
for having me uh great pleasure I should
as The Economist should show up earlier
so that I can figure out how to get the
text work
um so this is a joint work with a lot of
people
um I tried I think I haven't missed
anybody out but there's some wonderful
people in the US in Sweden uh in England
and so I'll show you a kind of a a
mishmash of different projects uh that
I've done with a bunch of them
so what I want to talk about is a
problem that uh I've been working for
about six years uh and I think this is
kind of what qualifies me to even come
to this amazing Workshop because I sort
of uh it's it's a it's a societal
problem it's it's a huge societal
problem and that is
um how we deal with a crisis of refugees
there's more refugees now than there
have been since the Second World War uh
and uh rich countries like the US uh
often bring refugees uh uh to the US and
what we've been thinking about is how to
help them relocate where should they
move and how can we sort of help them
get on with their lives in the best
possible way
so it's gonna be a three-part talk I'm
going to tell you about three projects
the first one is going to be it's a
project that's sort of completed in a
way and it's going to be about a piece
of software we built uh that uh helped
us resettlement agency move refugees
it's called Annie so I'll tell you about
that it's a simple static optimization
problem but it'll kind of help me set up
the problem a little bit and then we um
I think the correct word is we retired
it I think that's what you do with
software right and then we created a
dynamic optimization problem so it's
called Annie 2.0 and I'll tell you a bit
about how that works
um and then the final thing and this is
the thing I'm most excited about because
it's happening right now we've built the
first ever and this is the first time it
gets presented so this is this is the
treat this is the bonus um the dessert
um it's going to be the first ever
system that uses refugee's preferences
to match them to areas around the US and
I've been thinking about this problem
for six years I can finally say that we
have built a version of this and it's
very exciting
um this uh this piece of software is
called Ruth
um and it is allowing the agency to
match ukrainians who have been displaced
by this terrible War to the US so
there'll be no model
no lit review no equations stocks just
going to be kind of casual in general
I've never given a talk like this before
so uh it's uh it's it's merely kind of
my way of trying to put all of this
together so please interrupt me at any
point
um I I'd be happy to stop and clarify uh
anything that's not clear
um I'm lying actually I'm going to give
you a lit review since we're in Berkeley
because there's an amazing person
working on these problems in Berkeley
who's just moved to Berkeley and his
name is cook so if you find this person
on campus he's fantastic and his work
inspired a lot of my work and so I'm
very grateful to him okay so let let me
just tell you a bit about refugee
resettlement it's a
political thing ultimately in the U.S
how many refugees are admitted gets
decided by the president okay that's the
kind of first order approximation so the
president just signs an executive order
and that caps the number of refugees
that can be admitted so when President
Biden was elected he promised that he
would uh he would admit 125 000 refugees
in a year which is quite a few it's not
a a particularly huge number if we
compare it to the numbers that were
coming in during the Obama
Administration but at 80 to 90 000
people per year now after that of course
uh you as in the American public elected
a different president and that President
reduced the number of refugees to 15 000
per year which was quite unfortunate
given that we were working on Refugee
resettlement now just to give you an
idea of how politically divisive this is
President announces this around February
2021 about a month later it turns out
that actually he doesn't want to have
this number he actually wants 15 000 and
remember that's exactly the number that
Trump had uh kept in his in his last
year of course uh Biden being a Democrat
president uh really upset his caucus and
people complained and so the number then
went back up to 62 and a half thousand
but this is just to say that it's a
divisive political issue it's the way
that these numbers are set is extremely
capricious
um and uh it comes from this sort of you
know negotiation that is going on with
everything else that that matters so
um as Moon said in the very first talk
vote if you care about this vote vote
for whoever your favorite candidate is
but this uh this uh who you elect as a
president will matter for how many
refugees come to this country and where
do they go well they go everywhere
except I think instead of Wyoming it's
uh not very shaded in in a very dark
color but they go everywhere all over
the country so darker States admit more
refugees not per capita but in total and
so uh New York State and Florida Texas
California of course take the most
refugees by being the populist in the
richest States but refugees go
everywhere uh in the U.S
and so let me tell you sort of how we
think about this problem in a kind of
step-by-step way yeah the number you
showed us is the number of arables or
the number of uh admitted case perfect
so the cap is the match sorry can you
repeat the question oh sorry so Rad's
question was the number that I showed
you which is 62 and a half thousand is
that the number that was actually
admitted so that's a great question
we're going to come back to it later on
that's the cap okay so how many refugees
arrive as how many refugees all right we
can't exceed that number but could be
below that number part of the
justification for why Biden said
actually we're going to keep the number
at 15 000 is because after the Trump era
the infrastructure was for resettlement
was completely destroyed and so they
really couldn't actually have admitted
125 000 people in that first year and so
but keeping it at 15 was just kind of
really insulting and so they once
halfway as you saw okay so that was the
cat but thanks for a great question okay
so how does resettlement work it's going
to give you an idea of a step-by-step
process so this is managed by a bunch of
agencies different departments in the US
Department of Security
um in particular and so thousands of
people arrive and the Department of
Homeland secured in the state department
they decentralized these process to nine
resettlement agencies and so I work with
one of them
and the resettlement agencies are
responsible for finding placement for
the refugees around the country
and the way they do it is by having a
network of what they call Affiliates so
I work with a agency that was
historically the Jewish needs to
resettle Jews from Eastern Europe to
America in the late 20th century now
they resettle whoever comes to the us
but they have a network of synagogues
around the country in particular so
these Affiliates a bit like synagogues
and members of the synagogue might
donate money to to help the synagogue uh
re resettle the people
um now so why does why is this problem
interesting the reason why this problem
is interesting from a kind of
optimization perspective is that there
is a lot of good empirical evidence
causal empirical evidence that shows
that the initial match between a refugee
and a local area really matters for
people's lifestyle outcomes and that is
a non-trivial point and the reason is
that once a refugee comes to the U.S
they're free to go anywhere they want
they get kind of the rough processes
they get a five-year visa after five
years they can apply for a green card
they're here to stay but they can go
anywhere and so it is actually quite
surprising that the initial place where
the refugee is relocated matters for
their outcome the reason why it happens
is because often people don't move and
so they actually end up staying in the
community for a long time because the
match between the community and the
refugee can dramatically affect how well
people do
now the thing to that realize is like
the objective if you like right so you
kind of you care how well people do the
constrained bit is that the government
approves how many refugees had a very
local level one is allowed to have so
resettlement agency goes back to the
state department and says we're going to
uh uh
um we're going to relocate you know 25
people towards the Massachusetts and 75
people to palate out of California and
whatever and these numbers are binding
you really cannot exceed them once they
have been approved so this capacity is
limited it's not limited in a literal
sense of course if you if you if you
wanted to you could have doubled all of
these there's still tiny numbers of
people in principle but they are uh they
are capped by law and in particular once
the capacity is fixed let's say the
synagogue that is helping during
resettlement they sort of work their
resource around this number so you can't
just scale up like that right you
actually need to give people some
warning
um uh about how many people come in so
these uh these things are limited and so
the question is how do you
try to set up a sensible objective and
as I'll show you that's actually been
given to us by by uh by the US
government and how to optimize or
improve the outcomes of refugees within
the given capacities
of the things that is kind of cool about
being an academic and working with an
NGO is that you need to uh you you can't
just tell the agency where the refugees
need to go because ultimately legally
the agency is responsible for every
placement that gets made so on the one
hand you want to say hey here is my
clever system that's going to optimize
where everybody goes but on the other
hand you actually want to give a lot of
discretion to the agency to be able to
tweak things right and so can I put into
kind of carefully tread that
um uh that uh uh issue okay any
questions
yes
quick question about the capacity
because there are multiple agencies that
are resettling so that capacity like on
a government level is it for all of them
so it's for agency affiliate specific
right so you might as well just think
about specific agency and their specific
affiliate that affiliate will have the
capacity
right
so it's not like there's a capacity for
everybody in Pittsburgh there's a
capacity for this affiliate in
Pittsburgh and there's a capacity for
this other affiliate in Pittsburgh and
the agencies do the relocation
independently I okay now it's perfectly
possible that the way actually refugees
get housed this might be exactly the
same place so the audio this is looks
like the system is particularly well
thought through but that it's exactly
right but thanks for clarifying okay so
um in in as you will see in a moment
everything I will show you could be done
uh uh if we just re if the the systems
that we have here we'll just resettle
all the refugees in the US so there's
nothing wrong with that just so happens
you know it's difficult to kind of start
collaborations with agencies one by one
so we're working with one um uh
specifications okay so this is a paper
um about the kind of the first step of
this and kind of roughly show you how
the um it's very it's really quite
simple
um how the um uh anymore this
optimization system uh for refugees work
so here is my uh my one slide uh that I
show to agencies remember this is not
what I usually show to academics so it's
going to use words like state of the art
um and then I'll point out which bits
are actually state of the art of course
this is being recorded I need to make
sure all that my colleagues in the
agency don't suddenly think I've been
I've been fooling them but let me just
show you how that what the idea is so we
have employment uh uh uh prospects right
so we've got two bits of data
um we've got data from a from a U.S
government system called Iris so we look
we can observe who has been recycled
where I would say the last decade and
whether or not they got a job within 90
days of arrival that's going to be our
objective it's a binary variable have
you got a job within 90 days of arrival
now how much you get paid the thing that
we care about oh sorry not the thing
that we care about the thing that the US
government cares about is whether or not
a refugee has got a job within 90 days
of arriving to the US okay so we look at
that and then we put in advanced
that you see that's the first page uh
machine learning how to try and estimate
exactly what the employee the counter
factual so we what we observe of course
is a particular Refugee is arrived in a
particular area so we say okay well
given your characteristics if you want
to write somewhere else what would have
been your employment chances okay so we
estimate that as a model that we
estimate and this gives us a counter
factual for every possible refugees
given their observable characteristics
and there's reasons it turns out and
Kirk's work is in part has been
instrumental it's kind of showing that
it's actually possible to do this on
past us data uh because uh and actually
estimate these things carefully and
causes actually identify this from the
data so we've got these counter factuals
and then in a what do we add to this is
basically a bunch of constraints about
who can go where so I've already told
you about the capacity constraints but
there's a lot more than that and these
are basically constraints about uh what
kind of refugee can go where
um and uh that may be kind of a simple
example to think about is uh match on
language so if a particular Refugee does
not speak or a family does not speak
English
um it's very desirable that there is
somebody in the affiliate that can speak
their language right and so we want to
make sure that somebody only speaks
Arabic we send them to a location where
there is somebody who can speak Arabic
and so this is the kind of thing that we
can observe for our Affiliates and we
can make sure that this is satisfied so
there's a bunch of constraints like that
it's another pitch state of the art
good old good old uh open source
software can actually solve these things
so we put these two things together this
turns out to be a multiple
multi-dimensional map site problem why
is it an upside problem because refugees
come in families actually turns out to
matter quite a bit some some Affiliates
cannot take in too many refugees some
families are actually quite big so the
kind of knapsackness bit comes in but
anyway this is all uh easily solvable
you have a little matching engine we
even have little gears they move around
in the software and you get your best uh
overall employment outcome uh for all
the resettled refugees again I'll be
kind of a bit uh clear about exactly
what that means so the thing I should
say is that the match is a suggested
sure
are you
are you deciding something
are you Desiring subject to these
constraints who to admit or to give you
a list of facts great questions okay
sorry everyone heard your question
that's good
um so no so the refugees are given to us
so they admitted really uh there's a
very long process typically these people
have been a refugee camp for a very long
time they applied to come to the U.S
they go through a security clearance
there's all sorts of checks that happen
on them at some point they get admitted
there is also a little pre-process which
is which agency do they end up with you
can think about this as basically being
a lottery okay just kind of a uniform
lottery so an agency just gets a set of
refugees they're then responsible for
relocating okay but thank you for
clarifying anything else but hit it and
then done
so uh the you mentioned the objective is
overall uh employment outcomes so and
you mentioned also there are some big
families right so how would how should
we think about employment for like a
whole family yeah so we just added up
the prediction for each individual
family remember it's kind of linear and
we have some sort of uh chats that we do
where we say okay it might actually be
good that if we treat it a family weight
as the maximum for of an adult so you
can think about it in different ways but
if your probability of employment is 0.7
um and Kevin's probably into 0.3 I will
give that family a weight of one
does it mean that let's say you would
prefer to match three singles to
California that has a very large like
employment probability compared to like
a family I'll come back to this point
okay so hold that thought that's exactly
the right this is the problem with
people who do too much optimization they
see the solution before you even set up
the problem but you're absolutely right
that's exactly right Diane
I'll get anything past you with respect
to matches being suggested do you then
also provide options like if I like if
you make a basically you have your
optimal match you're saying this is what
the best option I'll show you how it
looks so you can see it exactly yeah
yeah so I'll show you exactly how it
looks yeah right
so one question is uh do you consider
that joint employment prospects for
refugees like for example I guess from
your answer to that it seems to just
like adopt it we just add them up they
could be done in a more sophisticated
way so if like uh your partner was more
likely to get a job maybe you're
substituting maybe you're complimenting
well actually this is this is a bit more
it's got quite too hard to get it out of
the data because you don't get a lot of
uh there's not enough variation for kind
of family composition in the data it's
just quite hard to do
positive externality if you send people
affiliate or
um so what I'm not going to tell you
anything about is what makes Affiliates
good at giving particular refugees job
they're going to treat them as a kind of
black box so it's a so I'm not even
going to care about what uh what are
these characteristics of the Affiliates
are
um it's a good question anecdotally and
honestly talk to any Refugee that comes
to the US the community aspect seems to
really matter
so people tend to really find it easier
to find jobs have been resettle to a
community from their country but this is
anecdotal I don't have I don't have kind
of my own evidence on that but thanks
for asking
okay can I keep going
okay great this is what it looks like
this was a response to Daniel's question
you get this kind of cool uh little
dashboard this was all built by that I
should advertised by one student okay
one student built this entire freaking
interface it's really amazing so here is
like this blue box is an affiliate so
here you see it says NC Charlotte so
this is Charlotte in North Carolina
um and these green boxes are the refugee
families
and so what you can do is you can grab
drag one of these boxes and you can put
it somewhere else you can put it in here
and it will tell you whether you're
violating any of the constraints or
indeed what is the loss in your
objective function so at the top you've
got the objective function so if you
imagine refugees like this you'll get
26.37 it's going to deceptively accurate
right or such that stuff to be precise
right
um and you can you can move them around
and you will see how it changes how it
changes the objective okay so this is um
this is about the discretion part but by
and large what we found is that very
little rematching actually gets done so
in terms of performance allow me to go a
little bit quicker I will just give you
an idea uh the area under the curb is
about 80 you might say is this good or
bad it is what it is
um and then we try different scenarios
so we kind of when we test the software
kind of look at what really seems to
matter so I'll just kind of give you a
very quick overview
um we can get the employment rate from
about 30 percent
to about 40 by doing optimization so
this is a 10 percentage points
difference is a 30 difference in terms
of employment so this is massive I think
um and then you might put in a bunch so
one of the things that happens is back
to the hear this question one of the
things that happens if you just kind of
run the model with the constraints put
in
um is that a lot of well the model talks
is a linear objective the model tells
you to put a lot of single unit families
to places that are really good at giving
people jobs and in our case it's a place
like Pittsburgh for example as it
happens it's a place that is really good
at giving people all kind of refugee
jobs and the more basically said you put
in all the single people who arrive
needs to clean men in our data in in
this specific data it's man and so you
might say this is not great because
suddenly we haven't got a balance kind
of a nice mix of families and and single
folks and so on right so what you can do
is you can put in a bunch of constraints
okay let's actually make sure that the
average family size is say about two
something like that right
um and nevertheless we still get a
massive gain in deployment it's not as
big but it's actually not so bad you can
obviously crush it if you put the
constraint in high enough you end up
getting in feasibility but actually even
in a with a reasonable constraint on
what the average family size needs to be
you can still get huge employment so
this is the first paper we published
about this
um and I hope this kind of frames
roughly what the what the what the
problem is okay
I should have said that the model gets
run once every couple of weeks
and uh
quota the capacity for a particular
affiliate is over a course of the whole
year
but everybody in this room hopefully
almost everybody in this room might
think okay this is not a very good way
of doing this right you can't just kind
of statically match people over the
course of the Year and hope that it will
give you a really good objective by the
end okay so then we wrote a second paper
which is about Dynamic placement
optimization and the um the uh the idea
is very straightforward right so if if
you uh if what I just said wasn't
completely intuitive let me give you a
very simple example
suppose we have two Affiliates Austin
and Boston okay neither of them are in
our data okay so these are made up we've
got three families and the capacity is
five and the green means like green Edge
means high employment probabilities red
Edge means low important probabilities
and the colors in between are somewhere
something intermediate so if you had a
static matching problem you just had all
the refugees
arriving at once right which you don't
um you could just kind of solve this and
match the the families in the best
possible way yeah let's just do this
once you know run a kind of a simple uh
knapsack algorithm yeah and then it will
maximize but you need to have everybody
here now of course families arrive over
time
and you don't get as much warning as you
would like you know in principle it
could be the case that the US government
would just say here are all the people
that we're going to admit over the next
year which you get about sort of three
months in terms of warning if you like
so
what would happen in this case if these
families arrived first you would look at
these guys and you'd think okay well
let's kind of uh uh up let's do as well
as we possibly can for these first
arriving families so what we're going to
do we're going to match them to Austin
so you can see so now I've only got one
unit of capacity left so the best match
for these families are to put both of
them into Austin
because when the next family comes now I
don't have enough space in Austin to
match this family anymore
and so what am I going to do then I'm
left with taking them to Boston of
course that was sub-optimal so if I'd
known
that Austin was this great place that
that could have let me match this family
I would have held this capacity back and
maybe match this person to Boston in the
first place and that would have been
better as you saw from the static
problem the question is is this really a
problem inside the the uh on our data
and the answer is yes okay so if you um
if you ran the following counter factual
I said okay imagine I knew exactly who
was coming in a given year and I could
match them perfectly that's what's
called optimal hindsight yeah so that's
the blue line and then suppose you did
the greedy algorithm we just talked
about you just match people myopically
every week how would the how would the
quality of the matches vary over time so
what I have here on the y-axis is
basically uh if you like that the
matching score just think about this is
like the employment probability of a
family over time of a family that gets
matched so the beginning what you can
see is that the greedy algorithm is
getting a higher score why is that
because it's using upper capacity and
these really good localities early on
because people are coming in and okay
great just kind of stick them into these
really good places you're getting higher
employment than the optimal height but
eventually
it starts underperforming and so what
you want to do is you're going to think
okay well this is a good area so you
take the kind of the integral here and
then you look compare on the
underperforming part and you can see
that obviously the greedy algorithm is
going to underperform okay so it's the
difference in between these two areas
and what we find you get a loss of about
10 percent in efficiency
um if you just readily optimize
the trouble is that
we can't do optimal Hinds because we're
not God right so God knows who is coming
but we don't
um and uh and so what we want to do is
we want to make sure that we're using
our capacity in the sort of most even
possible way so I'm going to come back
to this idea of a price capacity but you
know kind of intuitively think about it
in the following way we've got some
capacity and uh you know that we know
we're going to have left and some places
are just going to look more desirable
and so in a way they have a they have a
higher price
right so we're going to take that
pricing okay they're in higher demand
because they're desirable locations for
resettlement and we've got to take that
that higher demand into account okay so
I'll show you how we do it
um
so the ideal price of the plastic so
when you place a particular Refugee
family into an affiliate there's two
things that happen well what it
increases employment that's the obvious
thing but the other thing it's doing is
that it's taking away somebody else's
slot and what the what the myopic
algorithm doesn't do is it doesn't take
that thing into account it doesn't take
into that opportunity cost okay so put
into all of these languages in this
language because it kind of really makes
sense to me as an economist but I think
this is you know this is uh uh um uh
kind of if you like thinking about in
prices I think actually it's it's it's
it's really quite nice so the idea is
the following what we're going to do
we're going to myopically maximize
this thing minus this thing right if you
like the benefit minus the cost okay
and so how do we estimate this
opportunity cost well similar we're
going to look at the data we're going to
simulate the trajectory of arrivals
sampling from the previous arrivals
we're going to project what kind of
people are going to arrive through the
rest of the year and this turns out to
be a really good prediction this past
six months data so obviously the example
you might have in your head is what if
there's another war in Syria that starts
well of course then the composition of
refugees might drastically change but if
the wars already started after six
months your prediction of who's arriving
in the U.S is going to be pretty good
okay so indeed these kind of um uh you
you have to be careful about these
massive changes but they don't actually
occur that often okay dang it
foreign
out of curiosity about the distinctions
between different countries in the world
so like if I imagine Ukrainian refugees
in Germany yeah it's very much like
those people came earlier this year yeah
like they it came immediately yeah and I
don't know to what extent I'm curious to
what extent if you're thinking about
Syrian refugees in the U.S yeah only
come to the U.S after several stops in
between in refugee camps in other
countries uh would you basically be able
to use information because the journey
is so much longer yeah there's actually
better arrival information than what you
just have by by drunk so so there's two
reasons why really you should really not
use any of this for the German case one
is that the composition is going to be
completely different these are people
you know it's a it's a sample of people
who are able to travel across Europe
that's number one but I kind of more on
a more basic level
the U.S has very regular regularized
Refugee resettlement process right by
being sort of by having two oceans on
either side that essentially prevents
the only migration that irregular
migration that happens is on the
southern border right and so every
single person in my data set what came
by play
right and so they were admitted and
that's not what happened in German so a
lot of the things that happened in
Germany early on was that people were
kind of choosing where exactly they were
going to go themselves and the German
government did not kind of fully control
this process now kind of they're trying
to uh uh uh sort of change things but
having taken the sort of the initial
arrivals as given but for the people who
come by plane don't you know six months
in advance
not as much as six months in advance no
that's the problem yeah so we know much
we give a much less warning than six
months
later cool
yeah hi
so it looks to me
hello yeah so thank you so it looks to
me like if I asked off to my system
objective function that I would get a
job in the next 90 days I mean some
arrivals let's say I don't speak English
has a less probability yes and if I just
opt myself objective function they are
not important for my objective function
you're absolutely right so re-weight
people I I don't like this objective I
can say this on record but the objective
is given to the agencies by if I
remember correctly the U.S Senate
actually that there's a rule or a law
that basically says we want you to
maximize this objective so what they are
told to maximize in order to be able to
get funding for these refugees the
refugees come with a little bit of
funding for that first 90 days to be
able to sustain that funding they need
to maximize the objective and we all
here understand that a binary yes or no
employment after 90 deaths cannot be a
good thing for human welfare that can't
be good but it is what it is and
unfortunately on the one unfortunately
we can then take this immediately to
application on the one hand I don't know
how much more fun than good we're really
doing here but for the objective that
we've been given we can definitely
improve thank you yeah well
uh hey Alex hey uh so related to ola's
question I'm wondering do you have a
sense of how often your engine can make
sort of like Pareto improvements where
both people are better off like in the
in the example yeah you gave right it
was like better off overall but it was
worse off for sort of the most capable
person so for the static case I can tell
you the answer something like so given
the matches we make in the static case
about 95 of refugees have a higher
probability of getting employment under
our system it's almost a parade of
improvement which is really good so you
really need to check that right are we
doing this at the expense of others so
for sure the thing that really happens
here is when you arrive in the course of
the year that's the great inequity
ultimately right and unfortunately
that's just not in our control so if you
do end up you know uh coming in earlier
if you've been under the greedy system
like sure yeah the greedy system would
have actually placed you slightly better
as you saw in the picture but
sort of in a way the kind of Equitable
thing is to treat everybody the same
irrespective when they arrive in the
course of the year I think that's an
okay thing so that's precisely what this
algorithm is going to do yeah okay all
right can I keep going all right so
we're going to similar trajectory like
imagine that we're gods and we know
who's going to arrive then what we can
do is we basically solve the big problem
look at the LaGrange multipliers that
tells us exactly what the price quote
unquote of each affiliate is that is how
much extra employment would I get if I
relax if I give it a bit more capacity
to to uh to an affiliate and then we're
going to myopically uh maximize the
employment scores minus this price of
capacity that comes from the range
multipliers and then we thought we were
really clever coming up with this you
know this is a sort of like a pretty
obvious obvious way of doing it it turns
out that uh
um Alberto and Sid had already thought
about this and in fact it fits into a
beautiful class of algorithms for which
they proved remarkable properties so
um sometimes you know you think you're
very clever but of course uh said has
been there you know three three years
earlier so um
um how would the pricing approach work
in our example what would happen is that
essentially
we would look we would look to arrival
to remember this is our initial capacity
was five but then we know that in fact
Austin is very desirable so that's what
the
the simulating and then solving the
model back it would tell us look
Austin's really great
uh we should down weight how much actual
capacity there is in Austin and it would
actually be something like two so Austin
is costly it would then tell us the no
no no place this family in Austin but
place this family in Boston right and so
that will work so the question is how
well does this work turns out to work
amazingly well like scaryly well
actually so there must be reasons for
why it works really quite that well so
it almost tracks the optimal hindsight
where the purple line that's that's
Annie 2.0
um and as I showed you already this is
our greedy line this is the one we don't
like but look we're tracking more or
less perfectly what you would have done
in optimal hindsight right even though
you're just kind of you're really only
estimating this
um and why does this work so well so if
you look at price capacity right now you
know what price capacity is look you're
basically using it up exactly linearly
over the course of the year it's kind of
neat okay and this turns out to matter
quite a bit you're getting almost the
optimal hindsight employment somewhere
between 89 and 99 of the optimal
hindsight employment if you do it this
way okay so the thing that I'm hiding
here a little bit
and I want to very briefly mention and
this is why in a way this is the
software is cool because it doesn't
actually take away all the human input
and it turns out to crucially rely on
human input and I'll just very quickly
tell you how
so it turns out that you know as I
showed you on the very first slide how
many refugees arrive in the U.S is there
things that can get changed like this
okay and the thing to remember is that
from a refugee's perspective the year
begins in October and ends in October
but your American Administration changes
in January
which is annoying because you're halfway
through a year you've already start
matching some refugees and then
somewhere through the year new president
comes in and decides there's going to be
a new amount of capacity okay and this
can just change arbitrarily
um so what I showed you here was a
little bit unfair because here I
pretended like I knew exactly how many
refugees are going to come
now if you trust the official
announcements and just believe what the
American government tells you you're not
going to do quite as well okay so this
is the point really on the slide is that
actually the official announcements are
not kind of represent so things change
very rapidly but also there's just kind
of institutional lags and how many
refugees can possibly arrive when you're
putting in these constraints some people
already have their got their flights
booked
um uh and so on so what I asked the
agency I work with actually knows if
they have a really good estimate of
realistically how many people are going
to come given all the information that
they have and so what we had them do is
we we actually just looked through their
records about their estimates of how
many refugees they thought would come in
you trusted the official announcements
if you just took the press releases from
the White House you would actually do
really badly in fact I was you know
pricing based rule in some years this is
2017 yeah you know what happened in
2017. you do really quite poorly
actually so the um the the algorithm
wouldn't do very well at all
um and the reason the reason why it can
happen is that sometimes in some years
you have more arrivals than you expected
um and your algorithm might do very
badly why is that because you ended up
with with um with um uh more arrivals
and then you uh you haven't left
yourself enough capacity and so suddenly
the last people that you're placing at
the very end do extremely poorly you can
also have too few arrivals right this is
what happened uh uh in in 2018 in
particular we ended up with two few
arrivals so the algorithm really thought
Oh wait we're going to have all these
people still coming but they're not
going to be coming so what we have the
agency do is we have them give their own
estimate of how many people they think
are coming out to be remarkably accurate
they can usually predict about nine
months ahead how many refugees are going
to arrive and that's a great thing so
Karen monkin here who is the arrivals uh
um the arrivals director she basically
keeps track on this number to make sure
the algorithm always knows how many
people are going to be arriving whatever
the White House might say
and she is the human input you can't see
her face but she is she's she is right
there this is her using any uh any more
version number one and so just to show
you how it's now implemented what's cool
about the new version of The Nanny 2.0
it's the same thing as you saw before
blue boxes are the Affiliates and the
the differently colored boxes are
actually uh uh now the all that sorry
all the family is now colored in a
slightly different color and the reason
is that we're trying to convey uh uh to
Karen when she's doing this placement
that you can't just take the uh you
can't just take the family the family's
employment probability today when you're
placing a refugee you've got to think
okay how is this going to displace the
Future Families they're coming in so
these different
um these these different
shades of green and red basically tell
you what is the value of this match
overall from a perspective of the whole
year you have a red match it's basically
not worth placing the family there
because it's 2 too costly to take up
that capacity relative to how much
employment you're actually getting okay
so it's kind of simple visual all right
I have five minutes can I have seven
because I started late no I shouldn't
because I just started later it was my
fault okay so I want to tell you about
the last thing I have exactly five
minutes to do it
um I think I can manage okay are we okay
so far is the kind of the idea clear we
don't want to do static we want to do
Dynamic but really we're solving the
same knapsack problem but now over the
course of the whole year some of these
algorithms already turn out to exist
um uh and uh but the the uh the kind of
the I think difficult bit is really
getting this implemented and making it
work in the context that you're in right
so it's not just as straightforward as
taking such beautiful algorithm and
implementing it actually does require a
little bit of you know art too
so this project I'm really excited about
it's really it's it's alive
um and in fact any data I show you is
probably already out of date because
this thing is really happening at the
moment and this is an algorithm we've
built uh specifically to uh to relocate
Ukrainian refugees okay so the US
promised to accept 100 000 ukrainians uh
this is in addition
to the 125 000 that Biden promised to uh
to take in so these um
sorry this picture's quite
um hard to look at but the um the
um
this is in addition to the to the uh 125
a thousand other refugees who are coming
in
um and so let me kind of tell you about
what the process for the ukrainians is a
little bit different for for how the
rest of the refugees are resettled in
the U.S and the reason is the following
we are
um we've got our refugees there the
Ukrainian Nationals they're typically at
the moment somewhere in Eastern Europe
typically in Poland so they have fled
the family composition is very different
Ukrainian men are not allowed to leave
the country so it's typically women and
children and what they do is they apply
directly to hias they do not apply to a
uh to the U.S state Department they go
to highest and they say I would like to
be relocated to the United States
um and they basically have to show the
ability and willingness to relocate
immediately okay so we're going to match
we're going to try to match these people
as quickly as we possibly can and what
we ask them to do for the first time
ever we ask them where they want to go
in the US and we'll try to satisfy those
preferences
this is in part addressing this issue
that was brought up by a gentleman at
the back which was well why are we
maximizing the strange objective so an
economist they sort of think you know
what you should do is maximize people's
preferences right now we've got to make
sure these preferences actually kind of
good and informed but indeed actually
the maximizing preference sounds like a
very desirable uh thing for me to do now
we're going to match these refugees to
sponsors
these sponsors are going to be families
that are going to want to host these uh
Ukrainian refugees in the US these are
just individuals all over the country
and they're going to be affiliated with
kind of various ngos in particular
they're going to be uh you know there
might be kind of members of higher so be
working with the synagogue that is part
of the high ass Network
they committed to supporting the family
for six months they put up a bunch of
money to show that they can do it the
Ukrainian family does not live with them
they're merely being asked to help them
find accommodation and they applied to
this specific Visa I 134 and it's at the
moment the processing times are between
one and two weeks if you know somebody
who is interested in doing this it can
take as little as a couple of weeks if
you find a sponsor to actually come to
the US it's extraordinary it's very
quick at the moment okay now uh sponsors
basically we then try to make sure we
elicit a bunch of constraints in
particular the sponsors tell us if they
want to deal with difficult medical
cases pets are really big there's a lot
of Ukrainian pets that are coming with
these families
um and whether they can handle large
families the largest family of at the
moment is it's big it's still single
digits but it's a big single digit okay
and in particular what they do is they
try to inform the refugees about the
places where they're from so they
provide these kind of nice descriptions
we really encourage them to sort of
describe the area there really talk
about the schools and the parks and the
all the good things that they have okay
so what the refugees are gonna do
they're going to see all these profiles
of these places and they basically rank
as many of them as they want
um and if they don't rank a particular
place that means they don't want to go
there for sure they would prefer to stay
where they are
okay so you can rank as many places as
you wish so we um we have a um an
algorithm to do it I'm going to describe
it to you because it's a beautiful
algorithm and I we kept thinking about
what it should be and eventually I
remembered this paper by Neil sacral uh
who is currently visiting Princeton but
he's based at Brown he is an economic
theorist uh and he came up with this
algorithm when he was thinking about a
problem of matching people to social
housing and we just took his algorithm
with tiny modifications and applied it
in practice it's really elegant let me
tell you how it works so we haven't all
refugees are ordered in a queue there's
a lot of them right
um and the sponsors are going to arrive
infrequently so the sponsor is going to
come in they're going to see this huge
queue and the question is who are we
going to um who we're going to match
them to so when the sponsor arrives
they will arrive into their own location
so this might be you know San Francisco
New York Boston so the sponsor arrives
and they're in their own location and
they will look at whether there are
people queuing in that location so I'll
tell you how you end up in that location
in a moment but if there's somebody in
the locations you just match them
straight away and then you're out okay
but it's possible that you as a sponsor
you arrive in your location and that
locational queue is empty okay so I'll
show you exactly how what's going to
happen
but if the queue is empty what we're
going to do is we're going to go to the
main queue
so the moment you're thinking how do I
go from Main queue to locations I'll
tell you that so if there's if the
location cube responsor is empty we're
going to offer this sponsor to the
person who is highest in the main queue
now that person has an interesting
choice
they can either say yes I would like to
be matched or they say no and if they
say no
then they get to join any location or
queue they wish and we tell them roughly
how long it might take you to uh wait
for another match in a given location or
queue that you pick it's trying to
elicit your preferences over time and in
addition to your preferences over
specific areas okay
and so
um if this person said no they just keep
going to the next person eventually
somebody accepts you okay so that's the
idea it turns out this algorithm is
efficient in strategy proof it's
gorgeous it's beautiful so elegant right
it's exactly the setting that we have
okay so this is what the interface looks
like it's already been built it's
operationalizing and I want to tell you
one cool fact okay please allow me to
have one minute there's no one conflict
this is the first data I let we just
collected it this week this is the first
30 people that have arrived and I want
to disabuse you of one notion and the
the thing I want to disabuse you of is
that everyone wants to go to the same
place okay here's the amazing thing
about these refugees preferences they're
amazingly diverse they've got like 30
families that's all we've got so far
it's pretty small average family is you
know reasonably uh reasonably bigger the
largest one is really big
um and um and the first families they've
been matched by our algorithm have
already arrived to the US okay so just
so you don't think I'm just this is just
all in theory this has already happened
so we've had a few matches families are
arriving and so here is the coolest
picture I think here are all the
locations that we have
and the the different colored lines a
number of refugees who've listed the
places their first choice so let me just
show you the two cool facts about this
picture the the two most popular
locations are La New York okay that's
not a big surprise but 50 of the people
want to go to New York and the other 50
of the people want to go to La so you
still don't really know who wants to go
where right but look at what happens
when you look at second preferences
you're going to be able to resettle
everybody to New York it's basically
uniform okay nobody wants to go to
Newark and nobody wants to go to
Sacramento
um but it's like completely Universal
this amazing diversity of preferences
and this is basically the kind of the
key message so the reason why you want
to elicit these preferences because
they're actually really different it
really matters right what data you get
when you ask people about where it is
that they want to go so I have all these
um various ways of how you can work on
this stuff which I don't want to do it
the one thing I do want to end on I have
an extra slide if you've enjoyed my talk
and you want to praise me financially
don't do that to me please donate to
this guy okay he's just trying to he's
he's fighting on the front the winter is
coming they need warm clothes if you
want to donate please donate to him I've
given you the gofund page but otherwise
thank you so much
so much Alex why don't we have one
question while Swati up
at least someone who hasn't afraid
uh hi my question was uh if families are
joining only one location queue it seems
only the first preference matters for
the matching you're very good now here
is what we feel absolutely right in fact
it doesn't even matter where the place
gets ranked when I come to you I'm just
saying here is an offer to you and you
can just say yes or not
we still just say to them rankers
everything because it gives us better
data and better right there's nothing
there's no reason to lie so we're
assuming these preferences are still you
know meaningful but indeed it actually
doesn't matter and in fact what we're
hoping when more people start joining
the locational queues at the moment you
know people are just accepting matches
because there's a lot of sponsors
arriving when this stops happening we'll
be able to actually compare their
preferences with and without the waiting
time and I think that could be very
useful data it is true we are just
collecting this data for its own sake
but isn't it cool data right it is
different
okay let's thank Alex again cheers
our next speaker is Swati Gupta
hello okay yeah Swati is an assistant
professor at Georgia Tech
um interest of time let's just get into
her talk she'll be talking about
algorithms law and Society